OK, cool.
Um, so as a as, as sort of in
terms of the homepage, you've
kind of seen a lot of this. The
If you, if you need me to zoom
in at any point, just just feel
free and feel free to button at
any point as well. Just, you
know, think out loud. Be as
honest as you can. Don't feel
like you need to wait for me to
stop. Just just completely
interrupt me. That's fine. So
the only things that have
changed on the home page is
we've made this a little
smaller. This used to be 2
buttons and we've just made that
larger. So it's just to create a
new report straight from there.
We've also.
Added in saved reports this time
so I'll show you how to save a
report but once you've saved
your report you can now see
those on the home page and if
you click on yes. So this is one
that I did I think on Friday. So
if I click into that report
it'll it'll take you straight to
that report. And what you could
also do is you've got this my
saved here in this sort of top
NAV bar.
Um, so you can access them there
as well. So that's something
that we've added to the home
page. Everything else on the
home page is the same as what
you've seen before.
Do you have any feedback on that
initially in terms of having
your saved reports on the home
page?
Now I have a question. So right
now on the old platform, I go to
manage reports. I scroll to the
folder where the report is that
I want.
Because I can see other people's
folders.
So my first question is, am I
still going to have access to
reports that are in other
people's folders?
And then secondly, when I'm in
manage reports.
I pick a report, you know, maybe
it's just a matter of I don't
want to edit it, I just want to
run it because I need to update
it, and then I want to run
another saved report I actually
have to.
Like kind of go out and come
back in. Because if I if I click
another report while I'm in
that, you know, after I run one
that I've saved, it doesn't. It
makes me go out and come back
in, not out of the platform. But
I have to go back, pick manage
reports again, go back to the
folder. So I don't know that
this looks like this might be
better and I just want to make
sure I can see reports and other
folders.
Nick, do you wanna shed some
light on that one?
You will, yes.
OK.
There you go. Um, so at the
minute we've only built the
functionality just to save a
report, so you can't even rename
them or anything like that. It's
just the start of a 10th. But
yeah, the additional
functionality will be coming in
future releases, and no doubt we
will rely on you for testing
those bits as well.
So this is all the same, still
got search function, we've only
got still got three report
templates. You can see the
preview on the right, let's just
go into drugs create report.
We could show you this sort of
the the new bits to this page.
As you see in last time it loads
a data table. So there's quite a
few things that have changed on
this page. First things first,
in managed columns, this is
exactly how you saw it last
time. But what we've done is
we've got a sort of a hierarchy
for everything. So for example
you could see 31
classifications.
You could drill down further.
Um, you could select what you
want to regardless of how many
options there are. You could
always browse. You don't always
have to search, you can search
if you want.
Um, that's the only thing that's
changed there since last time,
and we've just made the drachen
drop a little more obvious. So
before you could drag and drop
and you know it wasn't as clear,
but it's now you if you're
dragging and dropping something,
you could see sort of a bit of a
shadow around it.
Um, so just to make it a bit
more clearer, that's the only
bits that I've changed in terms
of managed columns. Filters have
moved. Now the last time we
spoke filters, you had a
separate blue button here, um
with filters, and then you click
for that and then you could
apply a filter. Now what we've
done here is we've embedded it
into a 3 dot menu. So if you
hover over any column header,
you can see these three dots
that are there. So let's say for
example, company, if you click
on those three dots, that's
where you've got your column
options, so you've got sort.
Um, adding a filter? And you
could also pin the column to the
left.
So let's just increase the
number of rows here.
So two things there. Yeah you
could. It automatically freezes
the header, so regardless of how
once you Scroll down, that will
always freeze. And then if I
want to pin a column to the
left, if I click pin and then
that, that company will always
stay to the left regardless of
how much I scroll to the right.
So that's something that we've
added this time, the filters.
In the general have stayed the
same and it's just the
positioning we have added little
things like.
Um, you've got a search bar,
you've got what we had last time
is you could browse things, but
if they had more than 100 values
in them then you could only
search. We've changed that now.
So a lot of the feedback last
time was I still want the
ability to browse, so that's
fine. We've basically changed
that. We've given the ability to
browse.
Um.
We've not got all of the data
within the platform at the
moment, which is why you're
going to see a few empty cells.
The team are working on that.
That's nothing to be alarmed
about at the moment.
Um, so yeah, there's the filters
have naturally stayed the same.
We've just made a few
enhancements in terms of the,
you know, more than 100 values
you can still browse. Um.
You can now export. This is
something that you weren't able
to do last time, so if I was to
press.
Excel at the moment there is a
couple of performance issues, so
it takes a few seconds for it to
acknowledge that you've clicked
the button and for it to
download. And once it's ready,
I'll show you that. Because
it'll be good just to open up
the Excel and sort of show you
what's included in there as
well, just in case you have any
feedback on that.
Um, you could also save the
report from this page. So that's
the export that we've just done.
We'll open in a SEC.
Um.
If you want to save this view,
let's say for example you have.
You know, added certain filters,
you've you've changed a few of
those columns around, changed
the order. If you then want to
save it, you've got the save
icon, click save and then.
As it is, you could then access
it from my saved. So if you go
into here you can see you've not
got the ability to rename at the
minute, so it just saves it as
default. You've got some
information here in terms of
metadata, the date, time, where
it's saved from and how many
columns you've got.
So if you click it, it'll just
take you straight back into that
report. Um, same on the home
page as well. If you click it,
it'll take you straight back
into that report, um. And
something that we had last time
as well was just resetting this
table back to default.
Um, so you can do that as well.
So yeah, quite a bit of changes
in terms of your filters, your
exports are saved.
Any feedback on that? Yeah, so
when you export, I mean I get
you're building a report, so
obviously you have the fields
that you want because you're
picking and choosing what you
want on that report. But say you
know you have this report and
you have all these columns and
you want to kind of you want to
export just a subset of the
columns, you don't want the
whole report. When you export,
will you have the ability to
pick the the columns that you
want to export or you export
whatever is in the report?
That's a good question, Nick.
Yeah, I think, I think the idea
is that effectively what you're
doing.
In this view as you're picking
the columns.
That you would export
essentially, so there would be
no additional step. Effectively
it would be this.
OK.
So I guess, yeah, you would
manage your columns there.
Anything that you want to get
rid of, you could just remove
and then when you're ready to
export, it would just export
those columns that are.
Sometimes what I do is I'll run
a report and it's for a certain
purpose and then someone else
will ask me a question and I'm
like, oh, I already have a
report.
Now you know, maybe it's
something I just ran, for
example, and I'll open excel and
then I'll get rid of the columns
in Excel that I don't think that
person needs rather than going
in and rerunning another report
and altering it and saving it.
So that's why I asked the
question, no, that that's
perfectly valid.
I'm I'm fine with what you've
done here, but that's why the
question came up. OK. Thank you
for that. So let's, let's open
this export and then I will
maybe just ask for your general
feedback on what you've seen in
terms of the save, the exports,
the pinning, the column, the.
Um, the three dot menu.
What's happens?
Go.
Oh, it's gonna absolutely huge.
Um, so yeah, that that's the
view once you export it is
there, do you have any any
feedback on that in particular?
Yeah, I think it's fine. I mean
the reports now.
The Excel file just looks a
little bit nicer I think.
Umm.
But otherwise, I mean this is
fine, this is functional. So OK,
that's fine and thank you for
that. So anything else in terms
of the, the other things I've
shown, I know you've obviously
seen the last release so there's
not huge amounts, but any any
sort of views on the three dot
menu, how would you access
filters, the ability to save or
report anything in particular or
I think I like the three dot
menu, I'm used to doing that and
other.
That and other in other sources
and even in our internal CI we
have that functionality.
I think it's easier now having
everything in that little menu.
No, I think it looks good. I
think it looks good. I like
being able to export right from
here, so I think it looks good.
Yeah, that is good to hear. So
search the search bar still not
working. So we can't test that
the minute, but what we can do
is we can go into the data
Explorer. So this will still
active. The last time we spoke,
what we have done is I'll just
show you. So there's still drugs
and companies, um, last time we
spoke these were placeholder
metrics.
Um, there were done. It was sort
of dummy data right now. They
calculated metrics. So we've
updated that.
And we've also implemented the
same data table functionalities
on this page as well, so.
Everything you seen before, the
three dot menu, the filters,
export, save. You can also get
that on your overview page as
well. So any.
Any additional feedback I guess
on this index page?
No, I think it's fine. So the
overview page is what I can
create, right? So I have my own,
I can create my own overview
page or this is just what you
guys when I go in to evaluate
pharma that overview page?
This would be the overview page
for all drugs. So this will be
standard for anyone that comes
in. And then yeah, if you want
to filter down. So at the moment
we don't have the ability to to
sort of narrow down this
information, drill down or
filter and that will come in a
future release. So the idea is
that you can apply filters to
this data and then it will amend
this data, it will update the
data table below.
OK. Because where I was, where I
was thinking say for example
like one of the things I do all
the time is you know, what's the
worldwide market or I do these
company rankings on the branded
market and right now, you know,
I I go to reports and I just
rerun the report to update it
and nothing.
Usually ever changes in some of
those canned reports. I was
thinking if I had the ability to
create my own, kind of.
I don't know landing page or you
know, my own overview page, the
things that I do the most.
When I go into evaluate Pharma,
immediately I would see, you
know, the worldwide brand and
market or whatever I wanted to,
right? OK. So I think what
you're saying there is you'd be,
you'd want the ability to
customize this overview page, so
you could just add things that
are relevant for you.
And then that's every time I go
in that's what I would see, what
you'd see. OK, that's, yeah,
that's interesting. Fine. Is, is
do you think this stuff is
relevant for yourself? So you
know your events and your top
three, so you've got moas, your
indication level threes and your
therapeutic categories. Is that
of any help for you in terms of
this sort of middle of the
screen or would you?
As a matter of fact, your World
Preview just came out for 20,
you know, after 2028 and there's
a an image in there. This time
it's just top therapy areas.
Last time you kind of mixed
therapy and subtherapeutic
categories. But I actually asked
Anastasia to run me the data
that sat behind that because I
get asked that all the time like
what are the top therapy areas.
So having some of that right on
the main page makes it really
helpful because.
And once I'm able to filter or
like this is top therapeutic
categories, you're showing
three. What if I wanted to see
the top ten, will I have the
ability to change to?
Increase what you're showing,
you know what I mean?
Um, so that's interesting. I
think that's still in discovery.
Nick, correct me if I'm wrong.
Um, the ability to drill down
will be there. To what level? I
think we still need to define
it, but I think Nick will be
better placed to answer that.
Generally speaking, there will
be greater aspects of
personalization available, but
at the moment I think it's uh,
just, um, we can take your
feedback. Thank you on that.
OK.
Um, yeah, that's really
interesting actually. So.
The only other thing on the data
explorers is um slices. Now, we
looked at this last time and
there's not, there's nothing
much that's changed with regards
to the slices, the sort of
curated data views, um, But what
I wanted to get your opinions on
is this data that you see here.
So you can see, I've just gone
from overview to sales. So
naturally when I go into the
sales slice, the columns will be
more aligned to the slices
they're looking at, which is why
you see sales information.
The data is not here because
we're still populating all of
that data, but you could see,
for example, there's a lot of
space in these cells.
Does the width of these sales
cells affect you in any way or
do you have any feedback on sort
of the view that you're seeing
at the minute? I mean, to me
it's just empty space if you
were able to tighten it.
And you might get, you know, you
might be able to get another
year to show without having to
scroll. I'm not one. I hate
scroll. I'm terrible. I'm lazy.
I hate scrolling. So if I can
see what I need to see in one
view, I mean, you don't ever
have. I mean, if you know the
most you're going to have is 6.
Characters across.
Yeah.
You can tighten those. I think
if you did that, maybe it would.
Allow another year to show. I
don't know if that would give
you enough to show 2027.
OK, interesting. So yeah, I
guess what you're saying is if
there's space there, reduce it
so you could fit more in. If you
can, I mean, otherwise, you
know, I don't, it doesn't bother
me one way or the other. I.
Most times I'm gonna dump this
in Excel anyway and I'm gonna do
my editing there, so OK, fine,
so um.
Yeah, that makes sense. Or if
it's expandable, I know I like,
I don't know how technically
that's possible, but for the
technology or the product name,
if the product name is really
long, the column would expand to
accommodate that like
automatically, you know what I
mean? Yeah, possible, but I
throw that out there anyway as a
suggestion. I know exactly what
you mean because we have that
functionality. I'm just trying
to find something which has got
a lot of text in there if you go
into company and you go into
company.
Company.
Ohh, here we go. There we go.
Can you see that? This cell?
Yeah.
Let me just zoom in a little bit
so.
Um, yeah, Diana. So you can see,
for example, on this one or not,
all of the information fits in
that cell. So when you
naturally, if you hover over any
other cells, it doesn't do
anything. If anything's got more
information in there, it goes
blue and you see this expand
icon. Yeah, that's good.
Cool.
See. I guess, yeah, that's what
you're referring to, um. OK,
perfect. That's really helpful.
So the last thing I wanted to
show you is our drug item pages,
so.
If I was to click on.
Apixaban, if I'm pronouncing
that correctly.
Um, this will take you into your
specific drug item page that
before what we saw is an
overview of all drugs. This
would be just for this drug, so.
Again, you've got some.
High level information above in
terms of you know, the branded
name, the status indication,
etc. Some KPIs that will be
related just to that drug, not
all drugs.
Um, and then obviously your
curated data views as well. Um.
And your updated data columns to
sort of too much what you're
looking at?
Do you have any any feedback on
this?
Yeah, I think it looks good. And
if you put the ability to filter
on here.
So in other words, you're
showing five years worth of
sales, right, 22 and 2026 if I
want to go back or I want to add
out through 2028?
Will we be able to filter?
Or no.
Yes.
OK.
So we're building the ability
for.
Filters to be applied at on the
table.
And then those of you reflected
in the.
Metrics at the top.
OK.
Good. So yeah, filter this and
sort the topic updates
accordingly. Um, OK, cool. So I
think we have quite a, I think
we've still got another 1520
minutes. That's pretty much
everything I wanted to show you.
It's a little bit quicker just
because.
We, we, we've obviously we've
done this before, so I was only
kind of showing you the
additional bits. The only other
thing I wanted to mention is.
Do you at all use any other
service providers like data
service providers on a mobile
phone, or would you see the need
of it? At the moment evaluate is
only sort of best suited to a
laptop or a desktop screen size.
Potentially doing a bit of
research in terms of, you know,
is a mobile app solution
something that our customers
want us. So I thought as part of
this testing and we're speaking
to loads of customers, let's
just get our customers thoughts
on it. So do you have any
thoughts on that? That's kind of
interesting. So I don't have
like an iPad or a tablet. I know
other people on the team do
always tether to my computer,
but I will say that there's
times when I do get questions
that come up.
On a like a non business hours
or on a weekend and I'm not
home, you know it happened
Saturday. My VP sent me a text
and she wanted some information.
And I was like, well, I can grab
some stuff right off of our
signal, you know, our internal
CI site signal that I can use on
my mobile, on my phone. And I
was able to pull some stuff and
send her. Obviously, I didn't
download documents. I sent her
links to the pages where those
documents were. One of the
things she wanted to look at was
sales and forecast for that
market. And I said, are you
going to have to wait till I get
home? Because there's some of
that embedded in some of the
syndicated reports that I'm
pulling for you. I said, but I'm
not home and I can't get into
it.
Not going to go into evaluate
pharma on my phone because I
wouldn't have been able to.
Would have been useless. So in
those cases it's not a bad idea
and I'll tell you.
I struggle the same thing with
our, with our signal site
because people, you know, I've
had people say to me, well, you
know, executives and stuff
already. Senior leaders are
running in and out of meetings.
You know, everybody's on a
phone. Nobody's like, you know,
not always on their laptop or
they have an iPad.
So when we did the last redesign
of our portal, we they actually
the vendor used Google material
design and what happens is the
the view renders to fit whatever
it is device it is you're using.
So when I use signal on my
iPhone I there's more menus and
drop downs that I have to click
on in order to navigate. But I
have the option and I never I
mean.
I can't even believe people
watch movies on these things.
Like, you know, they're so
small. But in that case, when
you're cut short or you're it's
an emergency, you're in a
meeting, you can't get back to
your laptop. It's nice.
Having the option to be able to
do it, I can't imagine how you
guys would.
They are, you know, a tablet,
iPad or whatever kind of tablets
there are would make a little
bit more sense. I can't imagine
being able to search, evaluate
pharma on my phone and scroll
and look through, you know?
I don't know now if I needed a
quick number. OK, so I don't
know for multiple myeloma,
what's the size of the market
today? What's it going to look
like in 2028? That's two data
points. I can look. I can jot
down a number and e-mail those
numbers or text those numbers.
I wouldn't. I don't see myself
spending hours and hours using
evaluate pharma on a mobile.
But if.
You had the ability to give up
to do that. There might be some
people who would take advantage
of that. For me, it would when
I'm not home or I'm not in front
of my laptop and somebody needs
a quick answer, a quick number.
I go to other places for that
now because I can get to other
places easier on my phone.
But.
I wouldn't be running reports,
building reports off of my
phone. I mean, I there's no way
I would want to do that.
Sure. So in terms of if we did
have a mobile app or a mobile
friendly version of the website,
um, available then what would
you expect to run from there. So
I mean I guess there's you won't
be creating reports and stuff
like that. But in terms of I
would do it to just get you know
somebody said to me what's the
size of the worldwide
pharmaceutical market I want, I
would want the ability to run
one of my, you know, a saved
report so that I can get the
answer to that.
But it would be for quick
lookups some you know phase of
development that's something in
or whatever. That's what I would
use it for. I would not the kind
of work that I do and evaluate
farmer when I'm in there and
working. I would not be doing
that makes sense. So yeah
specifically specify my eyes
would like glaze over you know
these screens are just not big
enough.
And if you're asking me a
question and I'm like, well, I'm
in a meeting, I'm off site at a
meeting. I won't get, you know,
back in back into the office for
another 2 hours. I can certainly
get a quick answer.
Cool. That's really helpful to
know. Nick, I think you had a
question, um.
I I note that some ankle with
we've come to the end of the
sort of um the tour um and we're
sort of asking some additional
questions. Would you mind if I
ask some questions? Of course,
yeah. Would you mind, Diana?
Great. I'm gonna share my screen
if that's OK. Go ahead. Right.
OK.
So, um, you mentioned that your.
You can see that, Yep, the
you're a use case that you use.
That you go through very, very
often is um, kind of a global
market site. What's the
worldwide market or what's the
company ranking, right?
Yep. Um, so in the current um
system.
Uh.
So my question, so, so what's
the is, is the worldwide market
for a given indication something
like that, is that correct? It's
for the branded pharma market,
so market you guys created and I
forget who created it for me
couple years ago. So I just go
to the RX branded market report
and I click on that and I run
it.
And then Anastasia created one
because now they don't want
COVID in the in the market. So I
have two worldwide markets
depending upon what I'm running
it for, but it's the total
branded market.
Total branded market, OK. We
take out generics and we take
out any OTC that might be in
here. Understood. Got it.
OK.
OK, and if you go in my folder,
you'll see the reports. If you
wanna look at it, go ahead and
poke around.
Got it. OK. I I think I can
imagine kind of what that looks
like. Um. But uh, yeah. May also
go and have a look. Um.
OK, so.
In terms of these metrics?
I think, I think you said top
therapeutic categories is
something which.
It would be useful, right?
Because.
Um, you you've mentioned that a
couple, I think you mentioned
that one, you called that one
out.
And these are the ones
interesting.
Top mean the tab indications.
Yeah, because, you know, I was
recently working on something
where I was asked like.
You know around targets and you
know areas that companies are
focusing in. So you know MOA is
useful and and top indications,
but I see I would want to drill
right, so you've got solid tumor
indications I would want to see
OK, so out of.
The solid tumor, like what are
the ones that are at the top of
the list, right?
So that's why I asked you about
filtering or being able to drill
down this very quickly tells me
no surprise it's it's all, it's
all about oncology, but it's OK.
So for solid tumors is a breast,
is it lung, is it you know what
is it, I'd want to go further.
Yeah.
My slow sense.
We're going to be building some
charting functionality.
For this page.
We're proposing.
That the chart would show.
They essentially be a bar chart
that would show.
Sales by year.
Actual and projected.
Can you think of any other
visualizations that you?
Funny.
The well, let me ask you this,
you're going to put a, you know,
create some visuals which I
think would make this page even
nicer.
Would you give people the
ability to change the visual? So
have options? So there's a bar
chart. Maybe we want a line
chart, maybe we want a bubble
chart. People here like the
bubble chart.
Hmm.
Where the bubble would represent
the size of whatever, whether
it's number of indications and
development or sales or
whatever. The bubble would
represent the that number, the
size.
Gotcha.
Literally had to recreate the
bubble chart that you put your
world Farmer reports because
that's what they wanted to see.
But then when I update that
report a couple times a year, we
know your forecast get updated.
So running the data behind it
and having it sit made it a lot
easier for me because otherwise
I'm taking a screenshot and I
know we've talked on other
calls, so if you're going to
create.
Even if it's a bar chart, I'm
gonna go back to something I've
said on a number of these calls.
I want the ability to export the
bar chart. I don't want to have
to recreate the bar chart
because if I want to put it in
signal, I'd love for people to
be able to mouse over the bar
and see the number. Now I know
that people can't then click
through to get to evaluate
pharma unless they have a seat.
But all of the visuals that I'm
putting on my company
dashboards, and I'm getting most
of it from evaluate pharma, I'm
manually.
Creating you know how many hours
of time and hours of work that
is.
And I'm actually looking for an
alternative source where I can.
Get the visuals onto the
dashboard and have them updated
as you update the numbers
because I I've got 50 something
company dashboards I can't. It's
just not sustainable.
I mean I can show you what it
looks like quick if you want to
remind our refresh of what it
looks like, but this would this
page would be great if you had
visuals and then I want the
ability.
I know I asked for a lot, but
look, if you don't ask, what's
the worst? She tell me like no,
you you're like crazy. I can't
do it. Can you see my dad? You
see.
Go ahead again. Sorry, sorry if
you don't mind.
You can see my screen, right?
Yes.
Alright, let me go to a company
dashboard.
OK.
2026 worldwide sales by TA, Top
product sales, R&D projects
by therapy or this is all coming
from evaluate pharma. The last
time I we updated these 50
something company dashboards was
back in November.
Because this is all I go in, I
go to the Abbey company page in
evaluate pharma, I export and
then when I get this into Excel
I actually have to play around
with it a little bit in order to
create this view. Now if you
created if I had the ability to
export this.
In an iframe with an iframe code
because that's what I need. Then
it goes into this dashboard and
what I call interactive mode so
as people mouse over the bars
they see the numbers.
And I wouldn't have to do all
this manual work.
Does that make sense? That
doesn't make sense.
This that's what I'm looking to
do. So now I'm saying are there
other sources where I can get
this information?
As much as I want to cite
evaluate pharma, because
evaluate pharma is what I'm
using and I'll show you real
quick the ranking dash the top
10 dashboards that I have and
you'll see the ranking chart
that comes from what I create
from that branded ranking report
that I saved.
So I run the report and then I
go into PowerPoint and I
manually, you know, I do this
and then this gets updated a
couple times a year.
So.
Being able to export and being
able to get.
The iframe code where I don't
have to do all this manual work
is ultimately what I'm after,
and as much As for the.
Dashboards, for those, you know,
evaluate farmers, our trusted
source of information. I am
looking elsewhere because I just
can't sustain all that manual
work.
Because to me, here we are
almost November 2022, some of
that information, it's a year,
it's dated, it's a year old. I
don't even have year end sales
baked into that, right. So but I
just, you know, I have a
contractor that I work with and
between her and I, it takes
forever to update them and
there's always something more
important. But my concern is
over 14,000 people across
J&J are registered signal
users. You know how many people
are going to the company
dashboards on a regular basis? I
mean I'd have to look and do the
statistics, do the numbers, but.
I can tell you those top ten
companies are top ten
competitors people go to.
A lot.
And I want them to have the most
recent information, but you
know, I'm a person of an end of
1, so it's when I ask those
types of questions that's where
it's.
Ultimately where I want to be
able to use it and in order to
embed stuff.
Into an into a widget.
On a dashboard and make it, you
know, interactive. It's just,
and I say because I don't know,
I'm not techie, I say I need a
simple iframe code. I don't know
how simple that is or not, but I
have it from other tools that
we're using. The other option
for me is to dump the data and
give it to my, you know, the put
it in the tool that I use to
create visuals because
everything within that
visualization tool that I have
is embeddable and signal. So
that's just popped into my head.
Maybe that's a way to explore.
But I still would have to go in
and rerun all the data versus as
you're updating your numbers,
then the numbers in that bar
chart will automatically update.
That's what I'm after, if that
makes sense.
That makes a lot of sense. Do
you mind if I ask another quick
question? Thank you very much
for that. That was super useful.
Um, so quick question #2.
This is a drug page where.
Centering this truck page.
On.
The generic name.
To the compound and then you
have the products against that
generic name.
Ohh sorry this is the I'm sorry.
Yep. So you if you click on for
example.
Ohh.
I think I think I've.
One SEC.
Um, maybe not such a great
example because it only has
three rows, but um.
Where centering.
These drug item pages on the
generic name.
So basically if you click on.
A generic name.
You get.
A page which is centered on the
compound and then you have
products against that.
How does that sit with you in
terms of how you think about or
how you use or how you analyze
these these drugs? Do you think
about compound 1st and product
second or product 2nd and
compound?
Faster. Um.
I mean it depends. So for
example, we know you Meyer is
going to go generic, right. So
in cases like that, I mean this
is fine for me because I want to
see if I'm, if somebody asked me
for total sales for that
product, I want to see, I don't
care what company it is, I want
to see the total sales. I like
that it's broken out because
when I run those reports now you
know you'll see the compound
name and then you see the
companies that have it and if
there's any sales attributed for
each of those companies.
OK, that's interesting. So, so
it actually kind of works for
you because you just wanna, you
wanna see the whole picture
basically. Yes, that makes a lot
of sense. OK, because at that
time you have right, that's the
combination. So that 13, you
know.
Those numbers, it's, it's total.
Yes.
So.
Well, that's it.
So this is total sales for that
compound for that drug,
regardless of what company. But
then this table shows me all the
different companies.
That are working on that or have
you know some kind of
involvement in it and I can see
where the sales are?
Thank you so this gives you the
best of both.
That makes a lot of sense.
That was really, really useful.
Thank you very much. We're just
trying to work out if we should
also basically make a page for
each individual product as well,
but it sounds like.
From your point of view, that
wouldn't be kind of as useful as
seeing this like overall view
for the whole generic name.
Yeah, I don't.
Because.
If you click on any one of
those, would it take you to the
individual for that? Like if you
click on the first one, does it
take you to the NPS
Pharmaceuticals record, you know
what I mean?
Hmm. Company. Company. It will
eventually, yes. So. So we are
building a separate set of
pages. So I don't know. Yeah.
You know, see the the use case
for that. OK, that's really
useful for many other people
may, but not for me.
Hand back to Ankit.
Oh, well, I think with one
minute to go, we are pretty much
at the end. Um, any any final
comments from yourself, Diana,
before we close? Yeah, I mean
just from your timing
perspective, when are you
looking to really have this up
and running with all the
functionality?
Ready to go?
Roughly Q4Q3Q3 to Q4 next year
roughly.
But that that'll just be for
evaluate farmer only
subscribers. So I think for um,
I imagine Johnson and Johnson
has more than.
Just just evaluate farmer um
products subscriptions, so you
might be in a slightly later
migration wave.
Um.
But yeah.
OK.
I just want the report
functionality because the way I
have to get my save reports now
is a pain in the neck. That's
why I was asking. Plus it's I
like the visual, you know, I I
think you guys are doing a great
job and I think you're moving in
the direction that people want
because I put slides together
now. Nobody wants bullet points
on the slide. Everybody wants a
nice little picture of
something.
So you're definitely, you know,
definitely going to be extremely
useful. So thank you and thank
you for, you know, he's
including me and allowing me to
give my two cents.
No, I appreciate you being so
engaged and active, um, and
speaking to us per concept
release. So that is incredibly
helpful. So what I'll do, I'll
follow up. Um, just with an
e-mail, UM, why I would also
encourage you to do is just go
into the platform and test it
out yourself. I know you've done
that previously as well. So it's
the same way. You've got the
evaluate beta button and the
feedback runs in the same way as
well. You've got a little purple
sort of feedback icon. Um, if
you find that, you know we've
spoken and you've given a lot of
feedback on those.
Questions during the survey.
Then just feel free to drop me
an e-mail if you find that
easier. More than happy. Just to
take your additional feedback on
e-mail as well. That's that's
all good. Um, but yeah, that's
it. So we'll hope hope to reach
out in a few months with some
more functionality. OK, great.
Thanks guys. Enjoy the rest of
your day. Thank you too. Enjoy
your day. Cheers. Cheers. Bye
bye.